Film Courage: Can you think back to one of
your first scripts and when you look at now
where you are and having critiqued people’s
work and rewritten it and all of the things
that you’ve done in your career, what was
wrong with your first script?
Jill Chamberlain, Script Consultant/Author/Writer:
I had the chronic problem that is the whole
reason I created my method, the whole thing
that is behind The Nutshell Technique.
So everybody thinks they have a great idea
for a movie, right?
They don’t.
What you might have is the great idea for
one, you don’t have a story though?
You have what I would call a situation.
And I would identify that in my work as a
script consultant 99% of the time that’s
what writers are writing.
They are failing to write a story.
Instead they are creating a situation.
Life is a situation, right?
Life is…this happens, then this happens,
then this happens, then this happens.
That’s not a story.
Story is this happens which leads to that
happening which makes it ironic when this
other thing happens.
There’s this connection between the parts.
That’s the problem I’m seeing in 99% of
writers that they are creating a situation
not a story and that was exactly my problem.
I thought I had a great idea (this would make
a great movie) and I couldn’t understand
why I was feeling so blocked and why I was
having a hard time writing it.
I thought it was me.
I thought I must not be a good enough writer
or I must not be talented enough.
No, the problem was…well that might be true
too…but the other problem was I didn’t
have technique basically and technique and
technique to understand the difference between
what a situation is and what a story is.
If you just have a situation you are going
to be laboring to get from moment to moment
to moment and there’s not going to be a
natural connection and a natural progression
and so it’s going to feel stilted, it’s
going to feel unnatural.
It’s going to feel like bad writing.
But with technique, that’s the secret to
making something feel like an organic story
that has resonance and has power.
It’s not just reading somebody’s diary
of unconnected events, these different events
that happen to somebody.
There’s that glue that is existing behind
them that makes them coherent.
So I absolutely suffered from the same problem
that I’ve been addressing, that’s the
whole reason I created my method.
Film Courage: Do you remember where you were
or what was going on when you had that ‘aha’
moment about this?
Were you watching something?
Jill: I was getting kind of a similar note
to the one I described that people were saying
things like (they were using different words)
but they were saying essentially this isn’t
really a story, it’s a situation.
The only thing was no one could explain to
me the difference.
I had a sense of what the difference was.
I had good training.
I had studied at Columbia University.
I’d also studied with some private screenwriting
programs in New York City and learned a lot
of good things in these different programs
but no one was bringing it all together and
I could sense in this note, I knew there was
truth in what I was hearing even though no
one could explain to me how to transform it.
I got what they were saying and I had a sense
that there are (if I’m going to make a huge
generalization) two approaches out there.
One is a linear approach, a strictly three-act
structure, beat method kind of approach to
screenwriting.
And the other is a more character based, character
arc approach.
The problem I was having (and the problem
that 99% of writers are having) I could tell
belonged somewhere in the interaction between
these methods.
That these methods do not exist, if a story
is functioning properly, these are not separate
things.
Character arc in three act story structure.
They are actually very specific points where
they need to intersect and if you fail to
hit those intersections you are going to end
up with a situation but not a story.
So with this note I was getting, I started
analyzing movies, I started deconstructing
movies.
And I deconstructed hundreds of them, just
kind of obsessively taking notes and trying
to find these moments.
It took a little while and right off the bat
I could identify essentially eight elements
that are required to tell the story and my
method and these are interconnected elements
these are not beats, these are not moments
in time, these are elements of the story.
I’d say right off of the bat I knew what
five of them were but it took a little while
of analyzing movies and then it did happen.
It was kind of this breakthrough moment on
the last movie that I deconstructed in this
period where I was like “Boom!
The Eight Method.”
And I was like “Oh my gosh.
This actually works.
I can’t believe it?”
Film Courage: What movie was it?
I’m just curious.
Jill: You know…I don’t know that I can
identify the movie.
I had notebooks full of them at that time.
But it was kind of like Holy Cow…this actually
works once that last one dropped.
And then I could use those eight things and
apply it against every movie from then on.
I was like “Oh my gosh, they’re there,
they’re there.
I can’t believe it’s there in every single
movie.”
Film Courage: Well you go into several movies
in your book [The Nutshell Technique]?
Jill: Yes, I do.
Film Courage: From CHINATOWN to SILVER LININGS
PLAYBOOK, you run the gamut.
Jill: Yes, I made a point of doing that.
So the book…I’ll show you the back.
Film Courage: Please hold it up.
Beautiful cover by the way.
Jill: Yes, thank you.
So it’s a nice lovely large format book
and I recommend people get the paperback not
the kindle for that reason because it’s
just a beautifully designed large format book
and one of the big features of the book is
the last section I have in it 30 different
movies.
So it’s all in my one nutshell form (one
form), 30 different movies.
And so the book is designed for you to flip
back and forth when you’re reading.
I mention a movie so you can look and feel
how it fits in the alphabetical listing of
movies in the back you can see how that element
fits into the whole picture.
I have everything in the back from CASABLANCA
to PULP FICTION to AUGUST: OSAGE COUNTY.
Movies that are different time periods, different
genres, movies that you probably think almost
had nothing in common structure wise otherwise
maybe 3-acts (maybe).
I can identify these three elements in all
of these different ones.
So I just wanted to illustrate that this is
not formulaic, it’s not a formula, right?
We are talking about very, very different
movies that are not following one template.
No one would say that the template to PULP
FICTION and CASABLANCA are anything alike.
But underlying it at the very basis they have
the same structural that we are looking at
that are required for making them the great
movies that they are, they are the same right
things going on.
Film Courage: And you can send an email if
someone would like a graph?
Jill: Yes, so my nutshell form, the central
tenet of my method is my Nutshell Technique
form.
Basically I drew up these eight elements that
are required to tell a story and put it on
a one-page form for my clients and my students
and I rather glibly wrote on the first one
“Screenplay In A Nutshell” and that’s
how the name was born.
With this form, it’s a visual method, we
can see right on the piece of paper what’s
working and what is not working.
Anyone can download it.
My website is Jill Chamberlain (dot) com.
You can download free versions of these worksheets
for your own use.
You can take the Nutshell Technique and start
playing around with it using it for your own
stories.
What’s important (I want to emphasize) is
that it’s not just…it’s different than
the beat sheets methods.
These are not beats in time.
Four of these are moments in time.
What’s really different is the inner connection
between the parts.
I don’t know any other method in the 3,000
books on screenwriting that are on Amazon,
none of the ones that I’m aware of explains
the connection to between the parts.
Most of the books that you find on Amazon
that deal with structure they do what I call
a beat sheet method where they tell you you
are supposed to hit these pre-prescribed fifteen
or twenty two or however many beats that happen
in a typical Hollywood.
I’m throwing all of that out.
These are not moments in time other than a
first scene, a last scene, identifying things
like that.
These are other structural elements to the
story other than moments in time.
What’s important is the connection between
the parts, the glue that is going to hold
them together.
Film Courage: I’m wondering what a movie
looks like when it’s just a bunch of situations
strung together?
How does this look?
Let’s suppose a screenwriter has done this,
they haven’t fixed [their script], now the
film is out there.
What does that look like?
Jill: It feels episodic, that’s another
way to put it, where it’s kind of one moment
after moment.
It’s almost like we’re seeing separate
short films strung together, instead of one
coherent story.
And by the way, not every movie tells a story.
I’m talking about movies that tell a story.
Actually some of the films Richard Linklater
famously (and he has said this quite a bit)
that movies like SLACKER and BOYHOOD are great
movies, they’re not telling a story though
right?
It’s not one coherent story.
It’s looking at a slice of life, it’s
looking at different…it’s following a
character.
There might be some things thematically pulling
them in common but it’s not a story.
So not every movie tells a story.
I have to say that it’s extremely rate to
find a movie in theaters that doesn’t tell
a story.
It’s pretty unusual that Richard Linklater
is the exception to the rule where we see
something that is successful that we can be
moved by that actually isn’t telling a story.
The vast majority of the time movies need
to tell a story for us to feel satisfied.
We’re going to get restless.
It’s going to feel episodic.
We’re going to get lost on tangents.
Why are we following this character?
What did that moment have to do with that
moment?
There are going to be things that happen where
you are setting plants but you’re not paying
off.
And it’s a chronic problem that I see in
screenwriters that they are failing to tell
a story.